my first like real question i would have
to ask in the trailer um you have this
brilliant fight scene the one that
everyone was calling like the skyfall
fight scene for some reason yeah yeah
yeah and it was like featured all over
the trailer people were really excited
for it um but i just got to ask on a
personal level do you think you can kick
similar's ass in real life oh yeah
definitely
[Music]
oh my god this is awesome hey watching
you guys like it it feels like i'm
seeing friends right now oh this is that
is so heartwarming man thank you
dude thank you
how did i miss you guys what the heck
you have no idea the reality of what
happened that day we were standing there
like trying to attract you to you were
getting closer on the red carpet to us
and then you got called away yeah oh
really we're we're at which point okay
you know where there's so that the the
carpet had like the sign for guests then
on the middle section was where the
press was where like you guys were
walking down doing the interviews yeah
and then we were and then they had this
the spot where you all stood at the end
of the event to pose and like the big
chongqi signing and everything and so
basically we were saying do you know who
john campia is
no don't worry about it that makes me
feel better about myself so yeah
and then we saw you and brian there and
we were like okay that's them and we
were really just saying look i don't
care to meet anyone else but if we meet
them that would be the best part
of this caller
your youtube videos are so fun i am so
surprised that you were like uh we were
so happy when you guys were like showing
support to us for even covering your
videos so i was like damn these these
short films look like they take [ __ ]
forever to put together these kind of
shorts we wanted to make like when we
were kids in taekwondo class yeah yeah
fight scene's not easy to put together
man i put like one fight together in my
life and that that was a nightmare so
yeah that's like yeah yeah a lot of you
know you'll think like oh it's a youtube
video it's probably you know probably
didn't take that much effort to do no
man
the number one thing about youtube i
feel like did you everyone in marshall
club did you guys i feel like this has
already started uh everyone at marshall
club did you guys already uh were you
guys friends before or did how did it
work did you like
a lot of us were friends uh
well it's different with everyone but
we're all friends before and we all met
each other through martial arts whether
it be at in high school like one of my
homes uh um ryan or we know him as robot
like he just saw us do flips on grass in
high school on during lunch or during
you know recess or breaks and he would
just jump in and join us
dan dimach or daniel our third corps
member we met him through an open gym
so it depends like all of us we all kind
of just came together but we always have
this
organically together we're always we
know ourselves as friends first and then
teammates after gotcha so that's why we
call it ourselves the marshall club
family much like how jackie chan calls
himself you know the checkychan family
yeah for us it's kind of the same
borrowed the same idea i mean that's
sorry please continue no no no i'm just
saying it's not like an audition process
to join you know
we're just a bunch of friends who share
the same passion to make
to do kick-ass martial arts and make
you know martial arts films and youtube
videos i wish it was an audition process
because we would be auditioning
we're just going to become so you guys
would be family right away
that would be amazing
are you guys in california sometimes the
shots that i'm saying look like they're
in california no yeah we are we're
totally in california you're right about
that we're in uh
we're based in orange county
oh okay that makes more sense than what
we've never been able to successfully
stop you guys
you know you know what's funny is we we
have been stuck before like one of our
fans um
he noticed like we were we were filming
like at a
in our park like in our neighborhood
and there was a sign like a street sign
like at the edge of the frame very
little and uh for some reason he was
able to zoom in find the names of the
streets
you know find visited california found
the location
found the marshall club mobile so he
found my car pretty much and i had a
marshall club like jacket like in the
back seat he saw the inside he's like
all right this park next to this house
let's do this house
and then you know he was kind of able to
tell from the exterior that the interior
was really shattered and he opened the
doorbell wow
wow he came all the way from canada
wow
the thing is immediately i'm like creepy
but you have to i guess admire the
dedication
[Laughter]
yeah i mean i mean i i mean i wouldn't
like i mean we're kind of like you're
kind of like that with like donnie
underneath uh you know so it's in a way
like and then that's not to say he also
was able to pinpoint all our training
locations too and visited all of them i
mean we went there but you know but he
was able to find out
that's insane that is one of the
craziest uh youtube stalking stories
i've ever heard in my life yeah
that is nuts
this is just my room man i don't have a
setup like you guys right now it's just
just i mean that looks
i think your career is doing a lot
better than ours right now
you're on the cover of one movie's dvd
and now you're in one of the biggest
studio movies ever
i gotta ask though man um so my first my
first like real question i would have to
ask in the trailer um you have this
brilliant fight scene with um the
trailer it's featuring that like that's
the one that everyone was calling like
the skyfall fight scene for some reason
yeah yeah yeah uh so i think you know
what i'm talking about and it was like
featured all over the trailer people
were really excited for it um but i just
got to ask on a personal level
do you think you can kick similar's ass
in real life oh yeah definitely
i taught him everything everything you
know
initially like initially like in real
life not not just in the movies in the
movie i i played kind of his his coach
like his martial arts instructor like
growing up and i abused him right right
right in real life i initially started
on this movie as his trainer
which oh nowhere chemistry yeah i
started first two months um when he you
know for prep i was his martial arts
coach me and brian and one of my
teammates uh dui we
we just three of us just every morning
for two months we would drive wake up
five a.m drive out to the valley train
with him for like four hours
and um yeah however you think like i
abused him i abused shanxi and like
death dealer abused chungchi in the
trailer i guess you can say it was
pretty it's just as bad
yeah like hit like for him his biggest
problems were the flexibility and he
would even admit this himself i believe
he even said this on a talk show that
flexibility was his biggest um
uh his biggest uh you know
problem his biggest weakness we were
stretching him every day and i even have
like footage like like this on our
phones like just we're just like all
four of us just pinning him down and
just putting him in the splits and just
like
pushing him pushing his splits lower and
lower and he's like ah cursing at us
that's a movie in and of itself right
what it needs to be seen
yeah wait so you were like like the the
way how like you moving was for the
matrix films that's what you were for
him on this film
uh i guess you can say that yeah
straight but it wasn't we weren't like
practicing choreography or anything that
was locked down it was just martial arts
training just to build his foundation
because he's he's athletic he had a
tricking background so he was able to do
he was able to do the flips and stuff
but um you know what like martial arts
he wasn't as experienced and and of
course like
first and foremost like the foundation
of a martial arts of a martial artist is
um flexibility and and that was his
biggest problem so it was just working
on step one first you know yeah so
that's when i was younger my brother he
would do that thing where he put his his
uh like bend his knees put his heels on
the inside of my ankles and then stretch
me out so that way i could do the splits
event yeah we were doing that with him
except we had four of us doing that soon
or three of us three of us doing that
soon so that like so when he did the
split kick that's in the trailer that's
like that's really him doing it and you
guys got him to be able to do it to that
point i believe it was but i wasn't
there shooting that day but if it was
then i'm proud
i gotta follow up with that because like
yeah i bet that like i did my job
that's so yeah because i had no i from
watching the movie i would be like oh
damn this guy's had a similar like a
martial arts background his whole life
that's a bit of a martial arts martial
arts and tricky so he's he's very
athletic very and pretty acrobatic so it
wasn't like working with someone like a
normal actor or actress that was
completely new
so wait at what point then did you go
from you know getting him into shape for
you know the fights and stuff to
actually being the death team like at
what point did marvel's swoop in and go
hey i'll tell you guys the story how i
start how i got involved initially
um so it was brad allen who the late
brad allen who you know very
unfortunately you know passed away one
of the veterans of the jackie chan stunt
team and he he reached out to me on
facebook
very random and he's like hey i'm
looking for andy lee like i have an
opportunity for you and the thing is he
his facebook didn't have a profile photo
so i'm like this could be fake but you
know i'll take my chances with it and so
we met up for for lunch one day and it
was actually him and
like if you guys have seen him in
gorgeous gorgeous yeah you can't move
yes so like and he's a veteran in the
jackie chan stunt team so for me i was
like oh my god he told me he made a
facebook just to reach out to me so
that's why he didn't have the profile
for no way
because i
there was another brad allen i swear
this was like a fake one he's like no no
that bad allen's a fake one like this
one is the real one i made it just to
message you i told him like i've had my
foot in the door working in the stunt
industry and i learned really quickly
that
that's not what i wanted to do like i
wanted to do more and that's not to
downplay
what stunt performers do for us like the
stunt performers like they put their
lives on the line to make the actors
look good um i just knew that like i
wanted to do more i wanted to show the
world my face i wanted eventually i
wanted to show the world like what i can
do and i want my name on it
um so i i told him like our marshall
club what we do and our you know our
philosophy and our mission
and
eventually he told me okay well you can
start off you know you can help me
um by
uh training simu first and then you know
if the role opens up then uh i'll let
you know and as soon as it was uh
uh you know the death dealer role opened
up he called me right away and i've been
i've been let down so much by like
false promises in this industry because
it's normal oh we gotta roll for you oh
just kidding so he told me about it i
didn't think much of it he's like yeah i
got you know this royal death dealer
open for you you know it's actually very
you like it's this ninja character
your martial art style is very
ninja-esque like i it's it's perfect
like i i was like okay yeah i mean yeah
i'll submit i'll submit my stuff and
i'll just let me know and i didn't think
much of it until like
you know a couple weeks later i got a
call from uh the casting agency and they
were like oh yeah uh we would like to
book you for this role no audition
needed and
[ __ ] yeah
no audition he did and i was like oh
snap and i just at this time i had like
brian
my my my brother brian and my other
brother my marshall brother daniel um i
was from marshall club they were with me
the trio was together when i got that
phone call and we had this moment of
like
dude we came from youtube
um
so yeah that's how it happened so it
started off you know just helping out
brad uh training with simu and then
eventually it escalated to that that's
how it happened there's only a matter of
time to be honest like i think we would
say that when we recover something i
already knew that yeah i mean
and i'm still telling myself now we
remind ourselves every day dude this is
just the beginning what's funny was like
yesterday um we did a our very first
comic book signing i never thought i
would
be doing a comic book signing and it's
just like it's kind of weird but at the
same time it's like all right
this can't get don't let this get to
your head this is just the beginning and
we're just like we're telling ourselves
that every day
so well you i feel like i get the sense
that you're a visionary you're
determined you're very disciplined
and that like you said that it was only
a matter of time before something would
happen you believed that it would
i gotta ask though is any
which part of the process has any of it
been surreal for you
it's been surreal
since like
well first meeting brad was crazy
because i have
like
marshall club like i said like the
marshall club family we model ourselves
an actor after like the jackie chan
stunt family you know like we're
we call ourselves a family like
jackie chan is like my number one
so
you know and just being rubbing
shoulders with i've rubbed shoulders
with jackie himself and now rubbing
shoulders with brad allen it's like
it's been surreal since like working
with people you look up to
um because for me generally i don't get
star struck if i meet some like a
celebrity like i don't i don't care much
for it unless this person has had
a really positive impact in my life yeah
so for me first it was jackie and then
it was brad and that just kind of
escalated moving into the marvel film
you're working with all these veterans
where michelle yo and michelle yo wasn't
new either because i i worked with her
in a film previously and so we're just
working on two films back to back
and um tony lung and yoon hua i'm sure
you guys know already like the word's
been out you are you know old school
hong kong veteran and um just
it's just
the whole experience has been surreal
but i think for me like the parts that
like i will bookmark like in my life the
most is when you're working with people
who you you looked up to going up and
now you're sharing you watch them on the
big screen and now you're sharing the
screen with them it's like a just the
thought alone is like
yeah
that's that's probably one of the best
answers i could have ever heard from
something like that yeah that was that
was really that was really touching man
that was very touching because yeah brad
allen was i mean i saw gorgeous uh quite
a bit when i was kid i've seen both the
english and the original and um it's
funny because he speaks english in the
original but then they dub him in the in
the dump they don't like what's the book
but he's also the and who am i like i
remember watching the jackie chan
documentary of all the stunts that he
would do and i was like yeah and he had
he doubled for ron smartenberg the the
dutch kick kicking down yeah yeah yeah
he couldn't get the choreography down i
was like oh my god jackie chan getting
upset that's pretty scary
i mean you know i wouldn't want to be on
jackie's best side no right yeah
he's such like a fun guy i mean but with
this quality of like you still talking
about doing all the
uh like the stepping stones and that
whatever i remember
i did not know we i don't think you knew
either we did not know you were the
death dealer until
someone actually um the person who
introduced us is a friend of ours named
david gandy and then he's the one who
first encouraged us to watch your
channel that's how we got into it so
dave again he's like the main reason we
shout out to david gandy today not today
began it's what i was trying to do i was
trying to reel that out of you thank you
[Laughter]
um but i remember that when that first
trailer came out
there were so many thumbnails of your
character of the death dealer was any of
that like oh my god this is actually
happening or were you like nah i
expected it a little bit of that a
little bit of that but like you said
only a matter of time right and
and like like i know we're gonna we're
shooting for the stars so like we know
we know we're gonna be like the next
generation of martial arts action like
that's something that's already locked
in our brains and like in our destiny we
already know that so not to get cocky
with it but like when it gets like when
you when that stuff happens it's
it was a bit of like oh snap it's
happening but it's supposed to happen so
let's just let's just keep our heads
down exactly well i think to get to the
uh not to like blow smoke up your ass or
anything like that but i just think that
to get to the point of where you're at
just even skill wise creative wise you
got to have that level of confidence to
be able to do it or at least that level
of determination within yourself like
that philosophical perspective so yeah
i'm like it's manifestation
backed with hard work you know
yeah like the the experience is nothing
different from martial arts because
martial arts learning a punch or a kick
and learning to do it properly it takes
time and it's not just there's a whole
process you know you learn
you you gotta build the physicality to
do it so let's say you learn a sidekick
you gotta build the flexibility for it
you gotta build the strength for it and
then eventually you rep it enough
you just do this one sidekick enough
until that one sidekick means something
to you it's not just a sidekick now the
sidekick has
has
your
you want to be telling your life story
behind this one sidekick you know so
it's like this experience
of building like just
learning a sidekick to being able to
perform it in a way that's ultimately
you and mastering it
it's like it's just like how it is in
real life in real life you gotta grind
you to do your you got to do your due
diligence and um so the process of
starting from scratch coming up and
succeeding at something it's not like a
process that's lost on me it's it's it's
nothing new mm-hmm
did you i
did you get into
martial arts
with the intention of going into
filmmaking and fight choreographers i
met a lot of those i i did like martial
arts for like
for like 10 years in my in the past and
i would meet a lot of people in that
category especially at the rise of
jackie chan in in in the states was like
a lot of people were suddenly going up
dojos and stuff like that yes so
was that like part of your intention to
go to go to filmmaking or was it a
different draw at first i i was
definitely inspired by film like my
first exposure to any martial arts was
through film like i remember watching
you know wong fei hong jitli bruce lee
jackie chan kicking 10 guys at once and
you know like i said me being like
someone who got bullied a lot that does
something to you and i knew like at a
very early age i wanted to be just like
the heroes
like i saw on screen i didn't know that
i was going to do it like them that i
would actually be on a screen and do it
i just knew i was going i wanted to
change the world i already knew that at
a very young age
um
and it started as just a pure passion
for martial arts it wasn't to do movies
or for anything actually i would say the
the drive to do film or the industry is
driven is rooted in my passion for
martial arts
i wouldn't be working in this industry
if it worked for martial arts at all
like that's like i just feel like it's
my responsibility as a martial artist at
the highest level it's not to just get
good at it it's you want to
you want to spread it you want to
inspire people with it and change
someone's life and that's like just like
you know like the heroes did with me i
want to do the same and um it started
like i said as a pure passion for
martial arts eventually
just the way like my martial arts
developed and i i i started to find out
a little later on that it's like okay
now i want to do this in film i want to
do this from movies yeah um
and
so that is all backed up by just a pure
passion for it and i still like
you know you're working in the industry
it's business it is a business and you
know day to day if you want to like
succeed in this business you got to
compartmentalize your time to do the
business to do the work to do the grind
but at the end of the day no matter what
like even when we were shooting like
long days on set i would always come
back and force myself to go train even
if it was just like an hour two hours um
because like i know that's where my
roots are and i can't let that go like
that's something i always have to come
back to at the end of the day just to
kind of reroute myself so martial arts
is um
yeah martial arts is the the foundation
and that's where it starts and that's
where it's always going to be it's going
to be right there to the end
so you sound like one of the laziest
people i've ever known
to your point though with inspiring what
i will say is that that's one of the
reasons i'm grateful for this movie is
because
at least it's like the kind of fight
choreography that's in here it hasn't
gone away but i feel like it has also
not really been in like the american
films as much it's like there was like
jackie chan and then jet li coming here
and then matrix and
and uh then it's become like a lot more
it becomes a little bit more like jason
bourne-esque where it's very handheld
and gritty bam bam so then now it's all
john wick that's all like john wick
jason bourne and then to get back to
here with such a massive film where it's
like fluid and elegant and there's a
dance to it and then like they can't
like that that to me was like it's more
than nostalgia i was just like oh i'm so
glad to see this back on the big screen
again yeah
have you you guys haven't oh you guys
have seen it yeah yeah you guys have
seen it okay we left the premiere once
we couldn't talk to you we were like
there's no point in watching this movie
yeah i'm sorry
we've been
you reacted to one video and you think
we're friends
i think um i i do like to what you were
saying i think um
like i noticed with social trends
things cycle in and out so
like you said like in the early 2000s it
was like matrix you and wolping was over
here doing a lot of you know the action
and you know jackie chan was hot stuff
and gently was coming up
and then
you phased through this a decade or a
decade and a half of just realism like
john bourne a john wick born style and
and then
it's gonna circle back to
um
martial arts and the funny thing was
like
for those years like my teammates and i
would never let go of the martial arts
part we always kept it grounded and like
we developed our
you know the skill in that time
and we were like we always told
ourselves once the and this we always
foresaw this coming five years ago we
were like martial arts gonna make his
way back into the industry watch
something's gonna happen um and once it
does like we have to be there when it
happens
and the funny thing is we were there
when it happened and it's happening now
and so like we're just going through
this process and seeing how it's going
to play out you know constantly
reminding ourselves this is just the
beginning eventually we want to make
uh our own like martial club feature
film to
um we need we need to have a staple that
kind of shows the world this is us like
this is what we can do kind of like tony
john he's doing he's done a lot of uh
he's doing a lot of other films like
triple threat we want to have one of
those where people can always go back to
you and be like this is marshall club
they can they're working on these bigger
films but this is them so that's uh
that's kind of our next big step just
the writing process has been like two
years right and yeah like it's it's
frustrating but it's like
we got to remind we remind ourselves
like
good scripts take years to develop you
know
they take a long time they'll tell you
that
and uh
and uh i'm also working on i'm in
development for one to do another
because i'm vietnamese from vietnamese
heritage okay and um i wanted to i
always wanted to go back to vietnam so
we're doing like vietnamese american
crossover film oh hell yeah that's cool
yeah and i think i think uh you know try
to make my name over in vietnam and then
come back over here just keep my foot in
both doors and just you know just see
where that goes because that's always
been on my agenda i always wanted a rep
for the vietnamese people because like
you know um
you know thailand they had tony jaw
indonesia they had eco vietnam didn't
have anyone yet
like
i just feel like it's my responsibility
to do that so that's another one
good point good point yeah it could be
you yeah
so that's another one in development but
you know
it's all in development and anything can
go wrong
yeah i was gonna ask i was curious
because i i've seen like over the past
month or so you guys have been posting
these sort of like writing vlogs and
unveiling like your patreon to help you
know get your movie going yeah that
stuff like
what's the progress and how it's like
things like paper tigers and then
chongqi like getting this you know
different array of cinematic experiences
under your belt like affecting that
process you know you know what's funny
is um
marshall club uh we've developed a
thought a working style for ourselves
and that's a style we're gonna probably
keep with us all the way through so
working on a bigger hollywood project
there's a lot more rules um there's
unions
uh for example i worked on one recently
i'm not going to say which one but i
worked the one recently where like we
uh one of our teammates did a stunt
vault fell through a table
right
and then we had to reset the breakaway
table we had to reset the breakaway
table
and then like in our marshall club set
with ghetto we'll just like all do it
you know just like reset it let's go
shoot you know next shot like jackie
style hong kong style was very raw but
then it was on a hollywood set they were
like
let the prophets department do it i was
like look i'll just do this right now
i can just do this right now we can get
moving and get the shot but
you know it's it's that's just one of
many examples but um yeah we we have a
working environment in our team in our
dynamic that's and we keep it very fun
too we crack jokes on set all the time
and uh i think that's first and foremost
the most important you got to keep it
fun because why this is a passion you
know so yeah exactly oh yeah there's you
know for me
for me there's a you know work
for work and then there's like work for
the passion i always try to
compartmentalize it too
and is that part of the passion like
wearing all the different hats and kind
of getting to be in every different
department like yeah you know ideally
textbook that's not the way to go right
but i noticed and i take a lot from
jackie jack he's always been my number
one jackie is notorious for wearing all
the hats and i've seen it himself i
worked with him once he would bend over
and pick up the props and put it back in
place and like i'm i'm watching them in
real life i'm like dude like these
documentaries about him are they aren't
fake like they're real like so you know
i picked out a lot of that from jackie
learning
from the process and you know since
we're doing youtube
we
we don't have a choice you know we don't
have a budget we can't hire a camera
team or like
the lighting department we just gotta
learn to do it ourselves and i think
once you learn the whole package
yourself as an artist you can package
everything together to your specific
vision exactly well it takes on a unique
energy too well i would say with that
diy quality that you guys have it really
made me curious
on the choreography for shanxi because
it's like i've seen so many amazing
fights that you guys have put together
in like hilarious short films
and i know you've shared like a couple
little stories here and there which do
seem like the stories of your experience
sound like stories i've heard jackie
chantal which is so funny to me so um
but we're dealing with like the fight
scenes here
is it drastically different putting one
of these fights together for a big
screen film like and shooting it is it
like 100 percent different or are there
similarities like what or other things
about it that are more annoying or
challenging for a big screen versus
doing it yourself um there's a
a bit of both i think
because on a marshall club set
i'm the director so what i say goes so
um that's usually how it works over here
on shanghai you got a real director you
have destined you got brad who oversees
like the second unit director who
oversees the action and under brad you
you got like
fight coordinators so there's a
hierarchy you have to work with and i
think for this one i i had a lot of fun
doing it because i was there for
six months or something
and a lot of the time was prepping for
that one showdown
um that you guys saw so
uh yeah a lot of times working for that
one showdown so then we had a lot of
time and time is something we usually
don't have on a budget or true that's a
luxury so then
just imagine like it would have been
cake right but then each day was like
trying to one-up
we had the luxury of
locking down a fight and then
go and then letting it um seeing if it's
approved where we should change it and
if we do change it it has to be better
so that was where that's where the
luxury was first mentality so we had
exactly exactly so
yeah and whenever
i had the chance i would always you know
put my own flair into a
death dealer would be like represented
through my character so um
choreography wise i always had input it
may not work all the time
but um
but every time we did make changes or or
we in in the marshall club lingo we call
it op optimus prime like we would op
like
we would you know optimize or op the the
choreography it would have to be better
and better and better so we had that
luxury of time and not to mention we did
i did shoot some in between but like for
a lot of the parts was rehearsals right
right yeah so that's where it was
different and you're working with the
geniuses you're working with
working with brad allen who's
usually
i don't work get to work with a lot of
people in the industry who who would be
open to me as he is because
usually if i do work in the the industry
if i worked as a stunts like any time i
had any input
it wouldn't fly because my style was
just so hong kong so you know kung fu
but brad like was pretty open to my
input and you're working with people who
all collaboratively we want to just make
it better so it just works out that way
i love your answers because you you keep
answering a bunch of questions that i
already have down there
it's like it was like you edited it with
like everything i wanted to know about
because i know there's so much like
intricacy and one thing that i feel like
american films often miss on fights is
like especially the storytelling within
fights and i was like i noticed i was
present here so i'm like i feel like
andy must have had some input on this
yeah
one thing i i i liked about destin also
because dustin
um was always like he always looked out
for the story part respect like that
that's awesome in the action so even if
it was a kick like i wanted to rip a
cool kick and it would have works like
that i'm not i'm not convinced by this
kick i'm like oh shoot all right
and we got to change it you know
but it was like damn but this is like a
kick that's like andy lee like i want to
put this in the movie yeah
you just did a really good destined
impression
yeah it sounded just like him that's why
so many of your videos are perry yeah
that's so true
just for the purposes of you know you're
here we gotta ask some marvel questions
just get it in there speak around john
what do you got which ones here do you
think we can ask for like a for a marvel
specific question yeah i mean if there's
any other character in the mcu if you
had your choice of any character you
could step into the shoes of and bring
some of your martial arts flair to the
world who would it be
and follow who would you want to verse
against
it would be
death dealer versus shanxi
again
just go for it like that means you could
come back with a sequel man
why not i mean it's the mcu anything can
happen right yeah without spoiling
anything yeah you could be in the sequel
and uh i think the cool thing about
being death dealer is because you're
matched up just like how michelle joe's
in this movie you could you could be in
any other marvel film too
that's true too which would be cool
um what was tony long like off camera is
he as scary as he's
wrong he has this air of
tony lung has this air of like dude like
it was really hard to break the ice with
him he has his arrow
yo this is tony long and sometimes i
don't even know if it's him or if it's
me because like you know i get like i
told you i get star struck with you know
the veterans right right well i'm just
like
that's totally wrong and you know it's
hard for me to like
converse with him and yeah now i'm
thinking about it i don't even know if
it's because he's just like really
closed off and in his own world maybe it
could be his acting like you know just
acting technique i don't know but um
i a part of me a big part of me feels
like it's me and just me being
starstruck in the air of like yo this is
tony lung and like i can't get myself to
talk
i get that yeah yeah i would be afraid
i mean is there uh other than cebu uh
because it sounds like you spent so much
time with him is there another member on
the cast who you
uh found yourself really clicking with
the most yeah i mean i
uh
i've clicked with i feel like clicking
everyone like michelle michelle yo
obviously she's the queen i've worked
with her in a film like i said i worked
with her in a film prior so
it was like familiar and we had like we
had a bit of an exchange
an action exchange in the finale and it
was just like the chemistry was already
there because you know we worked
together before
and um and uh just outside of work
like we just get along and same with
aquafina
she's really funny man she's not she's
exactly like how she is and
in her shows and in the movies she's
just cracking jokes all the time
and uh
wrong i got along with wong also i think
i don't know what it was because for me
it's like i'm just guys like i'm a
it seems like everyone like has seemed
to take a liking to me also but i'm just
questioning like guys i'm like a new i'm
like a newbie here like i'm like a baby
like
but i think it's because um they've told
me that it's because i'm a very genuine
person that's why they like me so i just
try it i guess uh i got along with all
of them in that way
you're really a manipulative sociopathic
that's awesome so okay that's really
good to hear and uh did you talk to ben
kingsley at all i'm gonna go with a
conversation kingsley he wasn't
i don't think we worked together for too
many days so yeah i was able to say hi
and whatnot but i missed him for the
most part i wish i had to spend more
time with i got to spend more time with
him i imagine that you're like star
struck around searching oh yeah
it's weird because it's like
you're sitting in a
you know in a green room of too many you
know
like a lineup of you know stars and it's
like the air
all together is just like oh dude this
is like weird
very heavy you know
yeah it's very heavy in there because
it's uh
yeah because everyone here was
established everyone in this room is
established but me
so and
so i'm just like okay i don't see
anything stupid i don't want you to be
don't make yourself look don't don't
make a full out of yourself now i can
get that but
you're still established though and like
in terms of like the the internet
presence you had like definitely one of
the strong like a really strong one
you really think so i maybe maybe i
don't know i i try not to uh you know
the numbers don't i try not to let the
numbers get to me stay humble about it
because i think smart
yeah staying down like keeping yourself
in that underdog mindset
forces you to fight harder growing keep
climbing yeah very true and that's why i
that's why just one you know because i i
i
resonate a lot with um
kung fu movies sorry i totally brought
this back to kung fu films please please
do yeah i resonate a lot with kung fu
movies because a lot of the stories they
tell are revenge stories and stories of
like anger and i feel like i'm an angry
person on the inside so that's why i
have to channel it through the art you
know
and um and that like that grind
mentality comes from
something within and when you see
stories like that it resonates with you
because i i got bullied a lot as a kid
so that's why
that's why i have like
and
i have like a inner like demon i let out
through the art
and uh the journey also
i think that's why i've never forgotten
this first sketch we saw of you guys uh
the expectations versus reality
schedules oh no
i've never forgotten that and
that that idea of like
hey it's because most people i meet who
like do martial arts based like videos
uh
tend to only show like a very serious
side of them yes and it was refreshing
to see like oh damn they got like the
comedy down too yeah but also that that
dynamic like i remember the first one
that really made me crack up was when
that woman is being like uh like uh like
danger mom or something yeah and then
you know like you save her but in
reality you just like walk away and i'm
like that's like the inner child who's
afraid you know all of us so that i
thought i thought that actually
resonates so well with a lot of people
like that was the one that i felt was
like really connective and it was
it's always stuck with me like
specifically that bit has always stuck
with me which which bit which bit it was
the one where uh the woman's getting
mugged
oh and then it's like you fantasize
yourself as an action hero
and you save the day but in real life
it's like you're the scared little child
but then who's like go away i'm like
that's that's so i think it's so
relatable
yeah yeah
it's it's very relatable dynamic and
those videos
i think we did a couple of those during
quarantine and we were like shooting
those because it was just me and brian
we lived together and um we were locked
away from everyone else there were a
couple of those expectations versus
reality like those those fun videos we
did like on just a tripod
all on tripod reset the shots and like
in post we would like kind of
scale it to make it look like it's not
so tripody in a way so it looks so hard
smart yeah it's weird man those days
and now you're making big movies
you
you snug
well the thing is
the thing is i would be happy to go back
to making fun videos anytime you know
like those make me happy like being
you know just
like being on to be able to make fun
videos with your friends and laughing
and you know cracking jokes on set and
just like
making it up as we go like the freedom
of it and the art of it like you can't
you know and never want to lose that and
i would like be happy like i don't i
could be working on the biggest movie
but like i if you asked me to go back to
making dumb youtube videos i don't mind
it dude it's it's fun
it's fun
i could definitely see a scenario in
your career where you're doing these big
hollywood movies and then you have to
deal with like like how jackie chan
would have to deal with like man i hate
waiting around and it just takes too
long and like commodities if i get done
that i could see you go like i need to
go back to my roots
i can see i could see you happy
that happens all the time yeah i feel
like it's uh it's an innate like
artistic need it's kind of like how i
said like uh
working on you know bigger hollywood
sets and then
and then like sometimes it would be
draining and i would just go back and
train that's like me telling myself like
okay i gotta go back to my roots gotta
go back to my roots
and um yeah we would i mean i we would
shoot like we would i would always like
ideas for like dumb fun shorts would
always come like this after i get
drained of my soul you know so
it's normal and when jackie talks about
that i'm like dude i get that and you
know work on these big hollywood sets go
back to hong kong you know all right
well dude um this seriously this is um
i mean this is the most sincerity this
is like an absolute delight and i really
appreciate it yeah of course no thank
you guys for having me i always wanted
to be on your channel that means so much
you could go on any [ __ ] time you
want man
i'm sorry everything with like this
movie so far has been uh you know like
or anything lately would like do it zoom
stuff has been like coordinate with
someone somewhat coordinated and then
like you got five minutes to talk to
this person so i didn't realize until a
little bit before going on i was like oh
damn
andy hit us up and he's giving us time
today like it was such a surreal thing
of like yeah i guess i try to give the
interviews like
some wiggle room you know and i i really
appreciate that because there's going to
be a time where you won't be able to do
that there's going to be a time where
you're going to you have to be happy i'm
not there yet so let's let's uh
take advantage of it man yeah but dude
we'll let you go i know you're so busy
but thank you so much man again thank
you thank you guys so much for having me
this is really fun i'm taking my family
to watch shanghai on sunday actually so
yeah i'm i'm half asian
you already saw it so you're already
doing drugs your family will enjoy it
yeah my mom's filipino so i'm like we
gotta show some asian pride this weekend
mom let's go yeah
let's do it all right guys thank you
guys i'll talk with you soon buddy have
a good one
[Music]